that the queen made an address to the
nation
and that later that evening the prime
minister was indeed
sent him to hospital and 24 hours later
he was in intensive care and
very ill he was indeed too and a year on
we are still
dealing with this pandemic we are coming
out now
of another lockdown and today he will
update us all uh on the next phase of
unlocking uh england and taking us back
to a new
sort of normal it's going to be quite a
newsy press conference i think there's
lots of government reviews underway that
we're waiting
for updates on we're going to have an
update on the
covert certification review you know
this is
where by do you need to have some sort
of proof of immunity
a test or a vaccination certificate to
get
into a theater a sports stadium what are
they going to do
about pubs the prime minister certainly
flagged that as an idea a couple of
weeks ago
but it seems like the government's
backtracking on that a bit at the moment
in the face of fierce opposition
from many of their own mps who really do
not like the idea
of having to show that you've had a
vaccination
or you're covered free to get a pint at
the bar
so there's questions around that they're
also going to update
us on the travel task force you remember
this is all about
what do we do about our summer holidays
will the government lift
travel restrictions on may the 17th
i don't think that is likely at the
moment i think it's still
too early to say and actually there's
been
also a data dump from sage the committee
advising
the government on covid and they have
flagged in a
a series of papers published today
concerns about new variants being
imported
from abort abroad so there'll be an
update on that will you say it's too
early still to book your
summer holiday that's certainly been uh
the mood music
from ministers in the past couple of
weeks
that also give us an update on the
events
programme so this is all the pilots and
the testing
around getting us back into stadiums
back
to sporting events back into the theater
the government are going to do a series
of pilots
around the country uh linked to testing
to see about how that works if thousands
of us all get together in one place what
does that mean in terms of the spread
of the virus and of course the social
distancing review
when will the government drop that one
metre plus
rule how does that link back into other
proofs that you're covered free such as
the covid vaccination certificates so
there's definitely going to be plenty
to talk about but i think for the big
picture for all of ours
the good news today will be that the
government will say uh it's still on
track
uh to carry on with the road map as the
prime minister set out
in february i'm now beth let's have a
listen in
the prime minister good afternoon
everybody i hope you're all continuing
to enjoy
the easter break and i know that over
this weekend millions of people have
been
able to see loved ones for the first
time in
months and i want to thank you all again
for your patience because it is really
clear now that this is
paying off and it's your collective
efforts our collective efforts that have
given us the crucial time and space
to vaccinate more than 31 million people
and i'm pleased we've also been
able to support our overseas territories
so that gibraltar has become the first
place
in the world one of the first places in
the world to offer a vaccination
to its entire adult population
and the net result of your efforts and
of course with the
of the vaccine rollout is that i can
today
confirm that from monday the 12th of
april we will move to step
two of our road map reopening
shops gyms zoos holiday campsites
personal care services like hairdressers
and of course
beer gardens and outdoor hospitality of
all kinds and on
monday the 12th i will be going to the
pub myself and
cautiously but irreversibly raising a
pint of beer
to my lips we're also increasing the
number of visitors to care homes from
one to two
to allow residents to see more of their
loved ones
we think that these changes are fully
justified
by the data which show that we're
meeting our four tests for easing
the lock down as chris will shortly
explain
but and you know i'm going to say this
we
can't be complacent we can see the waves
of sickness
afflicting other countries and we've
seen
how this story goes we still
don't know how strong the vaccine shield
will be when
cases begin to rise as i'm afraid that
they will
and that's why we're saying please get
your vaccine or your second dose
when your turn comes and please
use the free nhs tests
even if you don't feel ill because
remember one in three people
with this virus doesn't have any
symptoms
and you can get these tests from your
pharmacies from pharmacies
or your local test site you can even
order them on gov dot uk and get home
deliveries
as part of our road map we're also
publishing today
on gov uk the early thinking on
our four reviews on the safe return of
major events on
social distancing the potential role
of covid status certification and
on the resumption of international
travel we set out our roadmap
and we're sticking in it and i want to
stress
that we see nothing in the present data
that makes us think that we will have to
deviate
from that roadmap but it's by being
cautious
by monitoring the data at every stage
and by following the rules remembering
hands face space
fresh air that we hope together to make
this
road map to freedom irreversible
thank you very much and i'm going to go
to chris for the slides thank you prime
minister first slide please
uh the government set out four tests and
these just
lay out some data uh some of the data
that lie behind
the decision that the tests had been met
the first test was that the vaccine
deployment program continues
successfully
and i think as everyone has seen over
the last weeks
the vaccines are being rolled out by the
nhs at a remarkable rate
uh continuing uh to to do so
over uh 31 million uh individuals have
had their first dose
and we're now in the situation where
people at the highest risk
are now beginning to get their second
dose and they're over 5.4
million people have received a second
dose so a first dose in
around 60 percent of the adult
population at this point in time
so at this stage uh that is heading uh
very much in the right direction
uh next slide please uh the second uh
question
uh was whether there is evidence uh that
vaccines are sufficient
uh and to actually reduce
hospitalizations and deaths in people
vaccinated
we had the original clinical trials all
of which were very
reassuring both the vaccines we
currently have and indeed
for vaccines we might get later in the
year but you have to see how things work
in practice
and looking at the data from people
who've been vaccinated
in uh the four nations of the united
kingdom uh
consistently we found a significant
reduction
in people who have symptomatic disease
estimated at around 60 percent
give or take and for people having
hospitalizations so more severe disease
around an 80 reduction from the first
dose
that makes two points firstly these
vaccines are highly effective
but secondly they're not completely
effective and it is absolutely essential
that everybody as the prime minister has
said who is called for a second booster
dose
goes to take that offer up because it
will increase the level of protection
and almost certainly increase the
duration of protection
as well next slide please
the third test was that infection rates
do not risk
a surge in hospitalizations which would
put unsustainable pressure on the nhs
and here you can see the number of
people in hospital uh with covid19 in
the uk
and these have been falling steadily now
from the peak
and they are continuing to fall which is
really excellent news because obviously
hospitalizations then translate into
people with long-term problems
and and deaths and alongside this the
number of people who are dying
has also been steadily decreasing and at
a faster rate
than happened in the first peak and that
may well be because of a combination of
the lockdown measures that everybody in
the country has been
involved in and done such a remarkable
job on plus
the effects of the vaccines on top of
that which led to an even faster
reduction in mortality and the average
number of deaths
at the moment is running at around 47
deaths
a day it's been lower numbers reported
over the
easter weekend unsurprisingly about 47 a
day
on average that's down from a peak of
around 1 300
earlier in the year next slide please
and the final test is our assessment of
the risks
not being fundamentally changed by new
variants of concern
and throughout this right from the
beginning we've said we do expect
there to be variants of concern along
the way and some of those may
potentially be ones that are
more able to escape the vaccine so this
is a this is going to be a
continuing issue but if you look at the
numbers uh here in the uk
of the ones and we have a very good
testing capacity in the uk so
some of the best in the world at the
moment and so
we have a high high degree of confidence
in our capacity to test for variants if
you look at the top line
with the b117 variant which is the
dominant variant uh
in the uk at the moment over
170 000 confirmed cases
the next one down south african variant
uh b14351 first described in south
africa may obviously have come from
somewhere else
uh the total number genetically
conserved confirmed there
is a much smaller number at 469
and that proportion has stayed steady
over time so there is no evidence
that this is increasing we are however
picking up more cases
uh because of testing at borders so as
people come in people are tested
and some people have found to have
variants and then much smaller numbers
again
for two of the other variants that we're
concerned about one
that was first described from brazil and
one of which was first described here
in england so um at the moment
although variants of concern will remain
an issue there is no reason
to see feel that this fundamentally
changes our
our position we've always known that
this was a risk so those are the four
tests
and there's of course a lot of other
data but these are just a snapshot of
some of the data we have
to support the government's feeling that
these tests have been met
thanks very much chris patrick to add to
that thanks veronica let's go
straight to catherine from basingstoke
when will residents of care homes many
of whom have not been outside in over a
year
be allowed out for a walk or a socially
distanced visit
to a cafe or pub garden i'm asking this
on behalf of my 94 year old grandmother
thank you thank you very much catherine
and i think that
uh catherine you speak on behalf of
millions who uh who want us
to to see more flexibility for
uh visiting uh elderly relatives in in
care homes and or allowing them to do
more and i know it's been
a very very tough time uh for for those
in in care homes who
remember uh how hard our care homes were
hit by that first wave of the
of the pandemic we've had to do
everything we can uh possibly to
protect them uh what we're doing from uh
from monday
april the 12th as i said just now is
we're allowing
uh more people to visit elderly
relatives in care homes
going up from from one to two and
catherine we're doing a review
uh right now on the specific um request
that you you make and i'm sure on behalf
of
many others to try to get that going uh
in a
in a reasonable and uh a safe way but
you'll hear a bit more about that
catherine
uh later on uh in the next in the next
few days
can we get them to matthew from norwich
as more adults become protected due to
the speedy vaccine rollout
is there a risk that covert 19 could
mutate and affect
children more if so are scientists
looking
at vaccine for children also
excellent question from matthew but i
think i'm going to ask chris and pat
patrick to yeah i'm happy to forget that
um well i think there's
there's no evidence that the virus is
going to mutate specifically to affect
children
what may happen as more and more people
become immune to the virus through
vaccination is that the virus will try
and get around that and to try to escape
the vaccine
that's a normal process that viruses do
so we'd expect that over time
which is why over time it may be
necessary to
update the vaccines maybe every year
every couple of years it'll be necessary
to have a slightly different vaccine
for certain vulnerable groups so that's
what we'd expect to change
in terms of vaccines for children that
is being looked at it'd be the same
vaccines the pfizer
study read out last week that they're
they're looking at this in in in
children
and so i expect to see more trials of
vaccines in children over the next few
months
but it'll be the same vaccines could i
just add one point on this which is
one of the few good things about this
epidemic and there are almost none is
that children are relatively unaffected
but for that reason you'd want to be
absolutely confident
that a vaccine was highly safe because
children are at relatively low risk
and therefore you want to be confident
that the vaccine is
incredibly safe if you're using it in
children in older adults of course the
risk of kobe is incredibly high so that
the risk ratios
look different thanks very much chris
thank you matthew
ian watson bbc uh happy easter prime
minister obviously some good news
today but uh on vacating passports they
seem to have achieved the remarkable
political feat
of uniting a former labour leader and a
former conservative leader against them
about 40 of your own mps
regard them as dividers so first of all
if they are to be introduced can you
guarantee
there'd be a vote in parliament on this
issue and secondly would you like to
take this
opportunity to reassure the skeptics
that while it could be useful for big
events
people will not need to take a
certificate to the local pub
to gain entry and very briefly if you
can ask this too on your review
documents they're sounding pretty
pessimistic about foreign travel going
ahead in may
when do you think you'll be able to tell
us that people can book a foreign
holiday
ian thank you very much lots of very
good uh points there
first of all on uh covid status
certification as we
as we prefer to to call it i think the
most important thing to say
to everybody listening and watching is
that uh
there is absolutely no uh question of
people being asked to produce
uh certification or uh covered status
uh report when they go to the uh to the
to the shops or uh to the pub garden
uh or to the hairdressers or whatever in
uh
on monday so and indeed uh we're not
planning
uh that for step three either uh
may the 17th as you know uh we're hoping
to go for
uh the opening up of of indoor
hospitality
uh and uh and so on uh we're not
planning for anything of that kind
at that stage but i think what is
certainly true is that
the idea of um uh
vaccination status being useful for
international
travel is is something that all
countries are
looking at i do think that's going to be
part of our uh
of the way people deal with it we need
to think about that
but uh there are basically three
ingredients to uh your covid
certification
or three ways that you can give
reassurance to
uh to others if you go to uh to
a big mass event and uh or
or ways you can that people can be
assured that the people in the room
uh don't uh have the risk of spreading
coping another one is your
your immunity uh so if you've had it if
you had the
virus before in the last or certainly in
the last six months you'll have
uh the antibodies number two uh
obviously is is vaccination status
but number three is is testing and
testing really is valuable i've been
talking about this for a long time but
the nhs as you know is now offering
uh free lateral flow test so i do think
that they are
uh for asymptomatic uh people as as well
i do think that they're
uh they're they're they're an important
part of of the way forward but
i want to stress that there are um
complicated uh ethical and practical
issues as i think i said last time uh
raised by
the idea of covid status certification
because after
for vaccination uh using vaccination
alone
just because after all many people um
will be for one reason or another
are unable to to get a vaccine for for
medical reasons for instance or
or perhaps because they're pregnant or
or whatever so you've got to be very
careful in how you
handle this and and don't uh start a
system that's
that's uh discriminatory um but
obviously we're looking at it
uh we want to be going ahead in the next
uh
a few weeks with uh some test events
some pilot events which which you can
see in the
uh in the in the the road map that we've
uh that we've laid out and
uh big events like you know getting
twenty thousand people into
into wembley on uh on may the fifteenth
uh that
kind of thing uh getting people back
into uh
a theater uh that will unquestionably
involve
uh testing uh to to allow the
the audience uh to really to participate
in in the numbers that
that people want as for um a
a vote on the on the issue uh well
i think that's we're taking too many
fences at once
first of all we need to to to work out
exactly what the
proposal uh might be uh but certainly if
there's something to put
to parliament i have no doubt that we'll
be doing that but i want to stress again
that that is not going to happen uh in
step two
uh april the 12th or step three may the
the 17th and i hope that
that helps and sorry on you you also
asked about aviation
and international travel and there
this is obviously we're hopeful uh that
we can get going
but on on from may the 17th we're
hopeful
um but i do not wish to give hostages to
fortune or uh to underestimate the
difficulties that we're seeing in
some of the destination countries that
people might want to to go to
uh we don't want to see the virus being
reimported into this country
uh from abroad uh plainly there is a
surge in other parts of the
of the world and we have to be to be
mindful of that and we have to be
to be realistic so what we're going to
do the the global
uh travel task force is going to report
uh later on
uh this week uh we will then be setting
out
uh well before may the 17th what we
think
is is reasonable so i i wish i could i
could give you more
uh on that you know i know that people
watching will want to know
uh exactly what they can do from uh from
may the 17th but
you know we're not there yet as soon as
we have solid information uh more solid
uh
data uh we'll let you know but uh but
that's where we are
for the time being i think that's uh i
think i think i either
you guys need to address those points
thank you very much ian let's go to
to she had call of itv
prime minister i appreciate the uh plan
to introduce covered passports
isn't coming in in the next few steps
but to expand on that idea
do you think it's fair to expect people
to show a certificate to do something
that was once
a normal activity and what support will
you provide businesses who will have to
enforce it and are you expecting them to
eventually turn people away who don't
have a certificate
and a second question if i may research
that was published in the british
medical journal a few weeks ago
found that adherence to test trace and
isolate was low
you're now set to roll out this new mass
testing scheme where you can get two
rapid tests a week
how much compliance do you need for that
to actually work and how can you be
confident that it will work given that
compliance levels of test trace and
isolate was so low
well she have actually well first of all
on uh your question
about um uh kovid's status and
certification and
i really direct you to what i said just
now to to ian
you you're taking too many fences at
once uh
where stages two and three don't involve
uh anything of the kind when we have
uh proposals we'll be uh we'll be
setting them out
uh and on um uh
your point about test trace and isolate
uh actually i think that
um testing has been
a massive advantage to this country our
ability to conduct
i think 112 million tests was the last
number
i saw um you know huge proportion of the
population already been tested
that's one of the reasons she had that
we've been able to
follow the path of the disease to
isolate its genomic sequence
in the way uh that chris was uh was
explaining
uh just now that's why we we know so
much about the variants in this country
uh that we that we face uh so it's been
of massive use to us in
in fighting the disease and i i think
that lateral flow
testing will be of great advantage to us
all
as we as we go forward i mean i do
lateral flow tests before i go out
on a on a visit uh to test whether or
not i might conceivably be
uh infectious uh i think it's it's a
sensible
thing to do the nhs is now offering as i
say these free tests
uh and i think people should should use
them
no i mean lateral flow tests
are effective at picking up people who
are infectious they're not 100 effective
so a negative doesn't mean you
absolutely haven't got it but a positive
that is useful to identify those people
who then need to isolate and you're
right
that testing alone isn't what matters it
matters if you're positive
and it's a true positive you isolate and
lateral flow tests are definitely part
of a way of
trying to pick up more people who
otherwise wouldn't be picked up
thank you beth rigby skye
thank you prime minister on february the
22nd when you announced your roadmap
you said the vaccination program would
create a shield around the entire
population
and put us on a one-way road to freedom
but now after june the 21st
it looks like you're asking us to have
twice weekly testing
and it's likely that we'll have to carry
around some form of covert certification
is that your vision now for what freedom
looks like for all of us and how long
are we going to actually have to live
like this
and to professor witte chile has one of
the world's fastest
vaccination rates but it's also just had
to close
its borders to slow the spread of covert
and stop the influx
of new variants from abroad is there
anything we can learn
from the chile experience and are there
any implications of it
on our own summer holidays
beth but first of all chris i'm sure
we'll want to answer the question about
uh
about chile but on the um
you need the vision for the for the
future and what the world will be like
after june the 21st i think a great deal
depends on the
continuing success of the vaccine
rollout and us continuing to satisfy
the the full tests and um
if things continue to go well i do think
that
uh for many people in many ways uh life
will
begin to get back to uh you know at
least some semblance of normality but
uh you know we're still somewhere off
there we've got to be guided by the data
and we've got to make sure that we we
follow the the road map that's the way
to get there and i think that a world in
which we continue to have
um testing uh is not going to be
too onerous um uh but
you know you're we're slightly putting
the cart before
uh the horse we need to make sure we get
through
um stage two right we
get through the april the 12th openings
uh get through the may the 17th openings
uh all right if we can and then june the
june the 21st
uh we finally open up a lot of things
that we couldn't open up
last year uh i think the things will
feel really very different for the first
time in
a in a long time um but we've got to be
pretty cautious
uh to get there i think we're still on
target i want to repeat one
key thing i i said earlier on there's
nothing in the data
that i can see today that would cause us
to
deviate from the road map as things
stand
on the question you asked me i mean
chile provides one
uh important example i think the other
extreme uh israel
provides another two countries that have
got very extensive vaccination
uh in israel the rates have really gone
down and are staying down for the moment
and i think it's really important we now
watch that
in chile as you say significant
remarkable effort by the chilean
people to vaccinate to vaccinate at a
high level
which is excellent but the re but they
have not had quite the same effect now
is this due to the vaccines used is this
due to
the timing of when things have actually
been rolled out uh
is it due to particular interactions
with other variants
we don't yet know and i think you're the
implication of your question which is
we absolutely need to learn from those
countries
that are ahead of us in terms of or
alongside us
in terms of vaccine rollout and those
are two of the key ones but there are
others
and you know as we get more data
i think the the information from other
countries as well as the information
from our own epidemiology
will tell us actually you know how much
can we gradually lower our guard
but this is the reason we want to do
things in a steady way because
the assumption that just you vaccinate
lots of people then the problem goes
away
i think chile is quite a good kind of
corrective to that this is something
we've got to
take steadily thanks very much
jane merrick the eye
thank you prime minister um can i just
ask a factual question which is what
about
children in relation to vaccine um
passports
will they be required to have these
certificates and
secondly prime minister it's a year to
the day since you were admitted to
hospital
with coronavirus did you imagine back
then
that we would still be in the pandemic
one year on and if i could also ask that
of professor whitty and sir patrick
first of all on the the the vaccine
uh passport question you know that again
jane you're slightly
uh taking your offenses all all at once
where we're
a way off um uh implementing or enacting
any anything of the kind for
anybody let alone uh let alone children
and i and i've spelt out the you know
the
the ways in which we might think of
doing that but it's not for steps
uh two and three uh in any event and i
suppose
a year a year on uh i i'm
actually filled with amazement that
science has produced so many
vaccines that's the thing i i you know i
remember having this conversation
uh with patrick and chris many times and
we thought and i was a great believer
and still
am in the virtues of of testing
as a way through because i could see
this thing would keep going and keep
going for a
for a long time but i never thought that
we would get
so many workable uh vaccines in such a
short order when you consider we haven't
got one you know i've got vaccines
against
sars or or aids or whatever and uh so i
think that's
that's the most stunning thing about the
about the last year
i mean i i fairly consistently from the
beginning uh
as did most scientists said now this is
widespread it's going to stay with us
for a very long time and i don't think
there's any surprise that it is still
with us now nor
is this going to magically disappear
over the next few months this this virus
will be with us for the
uh foreseeable future but as the prime
minister has just said
uh science is over time going to de-risk
it and it is doing so very substantially
with the vaccines
i think the thing which has surprised me
if anything is the speed with which
we've got the
number of vaccines we have rather than
the fact we've still got our
virus now but we will have significant
problems with kovid for the foreseeable
future and i don't think we should
pretend otherwise
yeah nothing exactly the same i think
before the first wave hit us we were
worried that there would be a second
wave and a third wave after it that
seemed
likely and unfortunately that's been
borne out across the world
and um aiko what the others have said
that the miracle in this is
is to end up with such effective
vaccines so quickly
really a remarkable um scientific
triumph
thanks or uh mesa hall express
uh thank you prime minister if i could
ask the
scientists the government dot review
document today doesn't give much away
about
when social distancing measures might
might start to disappear can you update
us at all on
when people who have been vaccinated
will be able to safely hug their friends
and family
and um prime minister some people have
said that um
covid status certification certificates
or passports whatever you want to call
them
are like id cards they're unbritish are
they wrong
um you guys first thing um
on the roll out of vaccines and the
effects of that i mean clearly the road
map lays out the steps and the next step
in terms of
being able to see people indoors would
be 17th of may
if the data are in the right direction
and that's true for people who are
vaccinated or unvaccinated it's
true right the way across the community
so that doesn't change
and what also doesn't change is that in
that five-week period it's going to be
necessary to look at data and we won't
be able to do that
until week four so we won't really know
what the impact is and we don't know
what the impact is yet
of the changes on the 29th of march so i
think there's a lot to do
following you know the opening up of
step two which looks
a very reasonable thing to do and all
the modelling suggests step two on its
own shouldn't have a big impact
we need to watch that measure it and see
it after week four
and i think only when we get through
these steps can we then start looking at
some of the other other aspects as well
and social distancing i mean i mean i
think
one is to sort of understand what that
might mean longer term
and it probably means things like hand
hygiene
things like the fact that people will
take time off if they get ill
stay at home rather than going into work
so taking time to
take yourself out testing to know
whether you've got it or not those sorts
of things i think
are likely to be important baseline
measures going forward
i can just add one thing to this uh
which is
as you go through the vaccination
program the protection to you
steadily increases first from the first
vaccine then from the booster vaccine
increases your protection and i hope
your newspaper will encourage your
readers to get their second vaccines
absolutely essential then the fact that
people who are around you you actually
physically meet
have have that had their first and then
their second vaccine that provides
another layer of protection
around you and then finally the fact
that vaccines across
a wide part of the population keep the
rates down so the probability
is low but remember you know the the
number of people who
actually got the virus at the moment is
about one in 370. so
uh we we really want to get those rates
down further uh before
uh we start to feel that uh the the
society as a whole has got quite a low
level of covet yeah may so i mean i
think
the principle of requiring uh
some people to uh have a certificate to
prove that they're not
uh passing on a disease like surgeons
who uh have to show that they're
vaccinated against hep b
or or whatever that's that's that's a
that can be a a sensible one but i want
to stress that we're
you know was was with some way off of
finalizing any plans for uh for covid
certification
in the in the uk uh the crucial thing is
for everybody to get out and get their
uh get their their vaccination when they
get your vaccination when you're
you're asked to come forward and uh as
chris says get your
your second dose when you're asked to
come forward the the uptake at the
moment
is fantastic and that's that's very very
important that
that uh it should continue and i think
we're seeing something like 99 point
common what is seven five percent uh
uptake in the
uh for the second doses which is which
is terrific and that's what we want to
see
uh last question stephen bocha city am
thank you prime minister you said
earlier that it was too early to give a
date for the resumption
of international travel but can you
commit to give the aviation sector at
least three to four weeks notice
of when this date will be to ensure that
they have some sort of clarity and
certainty going forward
and secondly if i may london has been
disproportionately affected by
the economic impacts of covert the
unemployment rate here is now
two percent higher than the rest of the
country and yet your government hasn't
given tfl a long-term funding settlement
the aviation and sector and heathrow
airport don't seem to have any idea
about when they can start again and
there doesn't appear to be any plans to
give central london
targeted economic support despite being
the nation's most important economic hub
as a former mayor of london why haven't
you done more to safeguard the capital's
long-term future
thanks very much to evan on the aviation
issue we're going to give as much notice
as we possibly can
we're going to want to get the country
flying again we continue to support
the aviation uh industry in all in all
kinds of ways but
uh the best thing for them is to is to
get flying and that's
that's absolutely critical i also i
happen to think that the london economy
is capable of bouncing back very
strongly
and the way to do that is to get uh
people back into the
center get the shops open again get
people moving again into they get the
agglomeration effects of
of a gigantic metropolis uh like london
working
again and but that requires people uh to
be safe it requires people to be
confident
and it requires uh the the vaccine
rollout
to continue to be uh successful until we
get to
to steps uh three and four and then i
think you really
will see a big change in uh the way
uh we live our lives now i don't think
that's necessarily going to come
in a rush i think people will take time
i think a lot of people have
learned to work more from home uh during
the pandemic
but my experience is when i was running
uh tfl is that actually there's a kind
of paradox of remote communication which
i mentioned before
the more people spend time uh trying to
communicate by zoom uh and
uh on all sorts of remote electronic
communication
the more they hunger and thirst actually
for direct
uh contact with the the people that they
need to
to talk to so i think that will all come
back it may take a while
stefan for it to come back but i
absolutely doubt that london
will bounce back very strongly
particularly once we get the uh
the life going again in uh the artistic
the cultural
uh sector the the theaters uh all the
rest that once that
starts going again as and and you can
see from the road map
how that can happen i think there'll be
a really big change in
in london as for the finances of tfl uh
i must respectfully remind you that i
left them in robust
uh good uh order and uh it is not
uh through any fault of uh of of my own
that the
the current uh labour mayor decided to
blow them on an irresponsible affairs
policy
uh we're doing our best uh uh to help
him out and we'll continue
uh to do so but uh i'm afraid uh you've
got to look at some of the some of the
decisions
uh that were taken by the the current uh
labour mayor
as well i i hesitate to make a
a a point like that but since you since
you rightly draw attention to
um the fact that i'm a proud former
mayor of london
i do think we could we could look at the
way tfl has been run
that doesn't mean we aren't going to
continue to support of course we are but
we need to have some uh some
responsibility uh from the mayor as well
and there was
i'm afraid a black hole in tfl's
finances
even before kovid began as i'm sure you
will
uh you will recollect and and your
readers i will recollect
okay everybody well on that slightly uh
a slightly
um london-centric note we're going to
we're going to end but uh there you go
the
the the road map continues to uh
uh be one that we are sticking to like
glue
uh it's uh it's uh
all the data that i can see uh suggests
to me that we have no reason uh to
deviate from it we're
gonna get to step two on april 12th
and uh at the moment uh things
still seem set fair for for may the 17th
but we will keep everything
constantly under review thank you all
very much
so there you are the prime minister
leading today's downing street briefing
joined by
england's chief medical officer chris
whittie and the chief scientific advisor
sir patrick
valance there let's give you a little
resume of what they had to say boris
johnson right at the start of the
conference wasn't he
and at the end of it saying that there's
nothing in the data
to suggest we need to deviate from the
road map
so uh shops all non-essential shops
gyms zoos he mentioned hair salons
beer gardens and outdoor hospitality in
england going to reopen
a week today he says he's going to
go to the pub and raise a glass he says
all four
tests that are required to ease
restrictions in england
have been met he pressed
as as chris witte did too
for people to get their second dose of
a coronavirus vaccine chris whitty was
asked incidentally how long he thought
this would be with us and he said a very
long time the foreseeable
future the prime minister was pressed on
what is widely known as vaccine
passports
this title the government giving them
covered status certifications saying
they wouldn't come in
yet but if pushed they would
be put to a vote later on we'll explore
that
as for travel he said he was hopeful the
industry foreign travel could start to
resume on may
the 17th and a global travel task force
would be reporting this week so plenty
to chew over
there let's bring in our political
editor beth rigby
hi beth what do you make of that right
right at the start he didn't have much
substance
uh at the top and all the various
categories did he just pressed on
on a number of issues the prime minister
yes that's right but what they have put
out today
is this which is the uh reviews update
and i'd like to tell you all that it
gave you lots of information about what
your life is going to look like
in a few months time but i think it's
fair to say that it's all still
work in progress and definitely that was
the sense wasn't it
from the press conference the prime
minister pressed on issues about
international
travels coveted uh certification
and pushing back just saying you're
trying to jump too many
fences at once when asked by journalists
around all
of those sorts of matters i asked him
well look if we have to have
twice weekly testing or covered
certification how long will that last
will it last the end of the year is it
indefinite he just will not go there he
doesn't want to answer
those questions politically he doesn't
want to answer those questions because
he's facing a huge rebellion on his own
back benches
from many mps that think that given
the extent of the vaccination program
over 31 million people
60 percent of the population now
vaccinated that it's time for the
government to
butt out if you like of our lives and
stop
uh asking us to do all these other
things and and have rules around social
distance in
uh and how many people we can see uh but
the prime minister they're stressing
caution saying that there's nothing uh
to see that uh he we have to deviate
from his roadmap but
we need to take it uh one step at a time
so what can i tell you that we know from
uh the review in terms of covert
certification
the document says it's likely to be a
feature in our lives
until the threat of the pandemic recedes
it talks about international travel as
the prime minister did
it notes that some businesses and
organizations
might want people to have proof of
cavity stay to say if you're going to a
restaurant
or a bar and so it's right for the
government
to provide the means to demonstrate
kavid
status so the document suggests that the
government really are going to press
ahead
on cavid certification even if the prime
minister
wasn't so equivocal about that at the
press conference
so that's still a work in progress on
covert certification this document also
says
it would be a temporary measure no
detail on how long we'd have them
and it reiterates that certification
would be based on
whether you've had a vaccine whether
you've had testing
or whether you have natural immunity and
it will never be required in essential
public services public transport or
essential
shops but when asked about the pub the
prime minister clear
that that won't be implemented
immediately but definitely keeping the
door open
for that to be an option further down
the line and then
in terms of global travel many of you
will want to know about what's going on
with your summer holidays
the government says in this document the
review that it
the state of the pandemic abroad means
the government can't yet confirm that
non-essential international travel
can resume on may the 17th you heard the
prime minister saying that
it was his hope that it would be able to
they're going to give us an update
on that later this week and they
have confirmed in this document that
traffic light system of red
amber green about different countries
around the world
and for the moment this document says
the government's advising people not to
book
summer holidays abroad until the picture
is clearer so lots of
hope there about our lives going back to
normal look the big headline there just
to reiterate is from april the 12th you
can go to the hairdresser thank god
goodness for that i need to go you can
go to the pub garden you can go
to the zoo you can go back into
non-essential
shops that's all on track for april the
12th and then may the 17th
still questions about international
travel the prime minister's saying it's
his hope
uh that that will be possible but beyond
that
what do our lives actually look like in
terms of whether we would be required to
have cloven certification
or test the prime minister just really
did not want to go there
he will be taken there whether he wants
to or not because the pressure as i said
is building not just from his own mps
but from across
bench mps from different parties very
concerned
about what they see as unnecessary
encroachments on our civil liberties
beth talk to us then more about these
vaccine
passports where do labour stand we know
there's a sizable
conservative rebellion at the moment
dozens of mps sakira stamina has called
them
unbritish and there are a lot of
rumblings today from labour mps
well sarkistarma has indicated an
interview of the daily telegraph
over the weekend that he as you said
thinks it's on british he's cautious
about it but labor haven't taken a view
about how uh their vote on it they
want to see more detail and just to
reiterate as well while the prime
minister there
uh when asked wouldn't be drawn on
whether there would be a vote
on kovid passports my understanding from
government sources
was that there is an expectation indeed
michael gove gave reassurance
to mps in private phone calls uh that uh
when he was briefing
about an and and doing a listening
exercise if you like about clayton
certification
uh that any change would be put to
debate and vote
in the commons uh but there is a sizable
rebellion brewing over 70 mps from
across different parties
the lib dems are opposed labour have yet
to give support they're looking at it
other labour mps mostly jeremy corbyn
opposed and then on the other side you
have
very powerful influential backbench mps
such as sir gray and brady
the chair of that 1922 back bench
committee very opposed as well in
writing about that again
in the daily telegraph today so boris
johnson really does
have a fight on his hands and it's
interesting because a couple of weeks
ago
at that liaison committee when he was
interviewed
by mps senior mps from across
the houses of parliament that was when
he raised the possibility
of being asked to show proof of being
covered free
to go into a bar and order a pint when i
spoke to him the next day he rode back
from that and said nothing has been
decided and then he raised the issue of
maybe testing
or immunity as proof not just
vaccination because the obvious point is
everyone under 50
hasn't even had the chance for
vaccination yet even if they want one
so he rode back from that and today
again equivocating
uh and maybe he is getting cold feet on
it in the face of what he knows
could be massive uh rebellions in the
commons
and he could even face a defeat in a
vote as things stand
right well as you say beth the countdown
on to the salons reopening less than
a week now and happy reading with your
documents thanks